but did you don't watch Game of Thrones
no I don't watch that kind of stuff what
do you mean just people fighting in the
past and all wait I'm more like it's a
historical document about the past
something that really had no it's not
yes I don't want no it's not that kind
of stuff bro my gosh maybe I'll read up
on it a little no no look at me no no I
know when you know dude I'm tired dude
work I'm tired too man what time is it
I know I know your arms hurt - no no
you're gonna do a couple more minutes
yeah I am gonna do a couple more minutes
while i grill you okay girl way dude oh
well dude or I am I'm tired of your [ __ ]
wake up with the king let's do these
[ __ ] making burgers over here you
liked it you know what you'd like to do
you like to distract me I do yes I work
games done know I do know
yeah you do technique don't do that
again either this away from you thank
you much morning blitz wait morning
blitz bro yeah it's starting to [ __ ]
hell of an afternoon in my ass what I'm
saying is daylight [ __ ] savings time
in my [ __ ] yeah but you know you look
nice tonight know what I'm saying to you
is this okay this is this okay is that
what I say that a lot right yeah I'm
sorry
don't be apologize it's not a bad thing
all right is it's a great show I think
you'd really like it it's like I in
terms of pop culture I think there's not
a better show out there what Tiger belly
no I mean Game of Thrones oh yeah I
haven't seen it I know you have it no
I'm not gonna let him do it he's on the
ground huh yeah
little no you're doing Oh offense
mechanisms that you do oh right and then
you try to divert me and I go yeah okay
I guess it's like Jedi Mind [ __ ] but I'm
Jabba it doesn't work with me
so you're [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't do it
dummy
your breakable you you watch it yeah Oh
what are these prescription pills on the
table
it's [ __ ] for my a panic attack yeah
well yeah I do
I'm about to stroke out back off the tee
what is that drug that they're always
putting in Asian people's food yeah
they're [ __ ] putting speakers in your
car sipping on soy sauce do back off I'm
gonna scale back on the soy sauce okay
now we're getting somewhere all right
but I listen right you gave me a
suggestion I listen yeah I'm sorry no
don't apologize cuz there's nothing to
apologize for
all right you're gonna watch Game of
Thrones okay I'll watch it every episode
oh yeah bro nah yes okay oh yeah yeah
yeah you said okay and it's a problem
how many episodes are there seven
seasons and what's it about
you're gonna do it I watched some of it